esta vez me preguntan cuántas soluciones
tiene el siguiente sistema de ecuaciones
lineales y me dan estas dos ecuaciones
que tengo aquí ahora para llegar a la
respuesta hay dos formas de hacerlo la
primera sería hacerlo de una manera
gráfica y ver que cada una de estas
ecuaciones me dibuja una recta y bueno
podríamos tener dos rectas que fueran la
misma recta y en ese caso tendríamos una
infinidad de soluciones o podremos tener
dos rectas que fueran paralelas con lo
cual pues nunca se intersectan y eso
quiere decir que no tenemos soluciones o
en su dado caso podemos tener dos rectas
que se intersectan en un punto lo que
quiere decir que tenemos exactamente una
solución sin embargo lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es trabajar estas dos
ecuaciones de una manera algebraica para
llegar a la solución y veas qué fácil es
lo primero que voy a hacer es fijarme en
estas dos ecuaciones e intentar cancelar
una de estas dos variables así que para
eso voy a tomar la primera ecuación y la
voy a copiar exactamente igual acá abajo
tengo 2 x + 4 james
2x
4 james es igual a 15 a 15 y ahora vamos
a fijarnos en nuestra segunda ecuación
sin embargo si yo lo que quiero es que
se cancele la equis estaría muy bien que
en la parte de abajo tuviéramos un menos
2 x porque 2 x menos 2 x esto se
cancelaría por lo tanto voy a
multiplicar a toda la ecuación de abajo
por menos 1 y que me va a quedar menos 1
por 2 x es menos 2x y después tengo
menos 1 por 4 y es menos 4 y menos 4 y
james y por último me va a quedar menos
1 por 13 lo cual va a ser menos 13 menos
3 y entonces se sumó el lado izquierdo
de estas dos ecuaciones y el lado
derecho de estas dos ecuaciones para
encontrar una nueva ecuación que me va a
quedar
bueno pues darte cuenta de que 12 x
menos 2 x estos dos se cancelan me va a
quedar 0 que es justo lo que queríamos y
después tengo más 4 y menos 4 y bueno
esto también es cero así que podría
escribir aquí más cero pero puede sumar
cero es lo mismo entonces mejor lo voy a
poner así
y del lado derecho me va a quedar lo
siguiente 15 menos 13 es 2 positivos
bueno pues date cuenta de que hemos
llegado a una ecuación bastante extraña
que dice que es 0 es igual a 2 y bueno
pues pensarlo como que esto no tiene
nada de sentido porque no existe ningún
valor x para el cual 0 sea igual a 2 y
es que 0 nunca va a ser igual a 2 no
importa que x 7 tomes nunca podrás
encontrar un par xy tal que haga que 0
sea igual a 2 si las equis y jesse
desaparecen de esta ecuación no hay
forma de que esto sea cierto por lo
tanto no tenemos soluciones
en solución y es que darse cuenta si
nosotros gráfica mos estas dos
ecuaciones vamos a tener dos rectas
paralelas es decir tenemos la misma
pendiente pero distinta intersección en
el eje y por lo tanto van a ser rectas
que nunca se van a interceptar y esto
quiere decir que no tenemos solución
ahora hagamos otro ejemplo más para eso
déjame bajar un poco de la pantalla y
vamos a trabajar con el siguiente
sistema bien ahora tenemos este sistema
de ecuaciones y qué te parece si hacemos
exactamente lo mismo que hicimos arriba
así que para eso voy a copiar
exactamente igual la ecuación de arriba
y tengo 14 x menos 7 bien esto es igual
a 21 y ahora me voy a fijar en la
ecuación de abajo y voy a intentar
cancelar x y para eso necesito que esté
2 x se convierta en menos 14 x por lo
tanto voy a multiplicar por menos 7 y me
va a quedar menos 7 x 2x bueno eso es
menos 14 x
14 x y después tengo menos 7 x menos
james esto es más 7 y muy bien y después
del lado derecho me va a quedar menos 7
por 3 lo cual va a ser menos 21 así que
hagamos lo mismo voy a sumar el lado
izquierdo de estas dos ecuaciones y el
lado derecho para obtener mi nueva
ecuación 14 x menos 14 x estos dos se
van menos 7 y 7 y estos dos también se
van por lo tanto del lado izquierdo me
voy a quedar solamente con 0 mientras
que del lado derecho voy a tener 21
menos 21 lo cual también es 0 y en este
momento tú puedes decir que aquí tenemos
también una ecuación muy extraña sin
embargo hay una ligera diferencia a la
ecuación que teníamos arriba recuerda en
la parte de arriba teníamos 0 es igual a
2 y acá abajo tengo que 0 es igual a 0 y
bueno ahora la pregunta sería para qué
par de x
y se cumple que es 0 es igual a 0
date cuenta hay una gran diferencia
porque no importa que x oye te tomes de
hecho aquí no tenemos involucrados ni a
x nadie pero siempre va a ser igual a 0
por lo tanto esto siempre se cumple lo
que quiere decir que tenemos una
infinidad de soluciones porque siempre
vamos a llegar a que 0 es igual a cero
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones no
importa que x 7 tomes y esto es porque
tenemos la misma línea recta si todas
gráficas vas a darte cuenta de que son
la misma recta aunque algebraica mente
no parecen la única diferencia que
tenemos una versión escalada la una de
la otra si multiplicamos la de abajo por
7 date cuenta que llegamos a esta misma
ecuación y por lo tanto son la misma
recta y como son la misma recta tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones ok
hagamos otro problema más y para eso voy
a bajar un poco más mi pantalla y ahora
trabajemos con este de aquí
para tratar de encontrar la solución del
siguiente sistema de ecuaciones lineales
charlotte da varios pasos correctos que
conducen a la ecuación menos 4 es igual
a menos 8 cuántas soluciones tiene este
sistema de ecuaciones lineales y bueno
ya ni es necesario ver este sistema que
tenemos aquí estás de acuerdo porque ya
tenemos el dato de que él llegó a que
menos 4 es igual al menos 8 pero esto
nunca es cierto estás de acuerdo menos 4
nunca va a ser igual al menos 8 como
esta igualdad nunca es verdadera
entonces tenemos el caso de no tener
soluciones y es que recuerda estamos
hablando de dos rectas que son paralelas
y por lo tanto nunca se intersectan eso
quiere decir que no tenemos soluciones
porque no existen ningún padre x james
que nos dé que menos 4 sea igual a menos
8 esto nunca es cierto o que hagamos un
ejemplo más voy a bajar la pantalla y
ahora tengo este de aquí dice para
tratar de encontrar la solución del
siguiente sistema de ecuaciones lineales
tranco da varios pasos correctos que
conducen a la ecuación
2x es igual a 16 cuántas soluciones
tiene este sistema de ecuaciones
lineales bueno ahora fíjate justo en
esta parte que tenemos aquí ahora
draco llegó a menos 2 x es igual a 16
esto quiere decir que podemos obtener un
valor para x si divido todo entre menos
2 me va a quedar que x va a ser igual a
menos 8 estás de acuerdo y si ahora
sustituyó en cualquiera de estas dos
ecuaciones x es igual a menos 8 puedo
obtener un valor para ella en este
primer caso me va a quedar 3 x menos 8
lo cual es menos 24 menos 24 7 james es
igual a 6 o de aquí que vamos a tener si
a éste lo paso para acá me va a quedar
30 y me quedaría la ecuación menos 7 y
igual a 30 estás de acuerdo
y si divido todo entre menos siete me
quedaría que es igual a menos 30
séptimos oyó puede sustituir justo aquí
me quedaría 5 x menos 8 lo cual va a ser
menos 40 menos 7 james esto es igual a
menos 10
a este lo pasó para el otro lado me va a
quedar que menos 7 y es igual a menos 10
más 40 lo cual es 30 llegamos a lo mismo
es decir que en este caso tenemos
exactamente una solución la solución es
el par menos ocho coma menos 30 séptimos
estás de acuerdo muy bien ahora hagamos
un último ejercicio para eso voy a bajar
mi pantalla para acá y dice para tratar
de encontrar la solución del siguiente
sistema de ecuaciones lineales le voy a
dar varios pasos correctos que conducen
a la ecuación 0 es igual a cero cuántas
soluciones tiene este el sistema de
ecuaciones lineales y una vez más si
llegamos a que 0 es igual a cero
entonces no es necesario ni siquiera ver
este sistema de ecuaciones cuando tengo
que 0 es igual a 0 esto siempre es
cierto por lo tanto tenemos una una
infinidad de soluciones esto siempre es
cierto y por lo tanto la respuesta es
una infinidad de soluciones